[Musique]
bonjour à tous je vous propose
aujourd'hui une nouvelle peu car vous
savez nos entretiens en voiture avec un
ingénieur qui cherche à sensibiliser les
chefs d'entreprise notamment ceux de
l'industrie à la transition énergétique
c'est le polytechnicien jean marc
jancovici
on va se retrouver directement dans la
voiture george pisi bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté cette interview balade
en pe car dans cette voiture à moteur
hybride
vous êtes ingénieur conseil
polytechnicien jeu dans la transition
énergétique avec votre cabinet carbone 4
mais vous êtes aussi le président
fondateur du think tank eu deux shifts
project qu'est ce que c'est de schiste
projet c'est une tentative pour faire
exister la question climatique au sein
du monde économique de manière
supplémentaire on va dire parce qu'il ya
un certain nombre de gens déjà qui font
des choses on s'est créé en 2010
est ce qu'on essaye de faire c'est de
lutter de l'intérieur ou d'agir de
l'intérieur sur la décarbonation de
l'économique et on essaye de le faire en
prenant un certain nombre d'entreprises
dont on se dit elles ont probablement
plus à gagner qu'à perdre a demandé elle
aussi à ce qu'on s'occupe sérieusement
de la question climat pour rappeler
l'urgence il ya quand même un chiffre
qu'il faut vraiment avoir en tête parce
que je suis désolé de le dire mais je
trouve que le monde médiatique a été un
peu défaillants sur le rappel de cet
ordre de grandeur
il faut savoir que cinq degrés sur la
moyenne planétaire
c'est ce qui sépare une ère glaciaire
d'aujourd'hui c'est juste 5 degrés donc
quand la terre passe de l'ère glacière
ou l'océan et plus bas de 120 mètres le
niveau de l'océan a pu battre 120 mètres
où toute la scandinavie et tout le
canada sont recouverts de trois
kilomètres de glace et où la france
ressemble au nord de la sibérie et ne
peut nourrir que cent mille hommes
cent mille 1 65 million aujourd'hui
c'est l'ère glaciaire autre vient la
température est simplement plus base de
5 degrés par rapport à aujourd'hui donc
quelques degrés de hausse de la moyenne
planétaire en un siècle
les gens pensent que c'est juste une
affaire dont on va avoir un peu plus
chaud dans les villes il faut
climatisé c'est la guerre partout pour
moi 5 degrés de plus en un siècle
c'est vraiment la guerre c'est la guerre
partout parce que ils manqueront donc 13
sur les ressources les ressources
agricoles le déplacement des
implantations urbaines
il faut savoir que quelques degrés de
hausse en un siècle c'est la certitude
que le niveau de l'océan montrent à 10
mètres ou plus en quelques siècles 10
mètres ou plus sannois toutes les
installations portuaires toutes les
villes portuaires au monde le tir de la
floride est sous l'eau enfin donc la
menace est réelle urgence il ira même si
on regarde aujourd'hui ce qui se passe
sur le pourtour du bassin méditerranéen
les gens aussi tous en tête la variation
de température mais la variation de
température va avec une variation des
précipitations
il ya un certain nombre de zones dans le
monde qui vont s'assécher dans le cadre
du réchauffement climatique dont le
pourtour du bassin méditerranéen c'est à
dire chez nous bon et quand vous
regardez bien ce qui s'est passé au
moment des printemps arabes et au
déclenchement de la guerre civile en
syrie on retrouve à l'origine de ces
événements des facteurs 4s alimentaire
très fort qui a lui même été provoquée
notamment par une sécheresse
croissante sur le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen donc les conséquences
désagréables et le million de réfugiés
qu'on est en train de ne pas savoir
gérer en europe sont déjà là il faut pas
penser on est déjà dans les conséquences
mais on y est déjà
bon mais alors revenons à votre démarche
et l'hydrogène et donc je me dis imposer
une taxe carbone ou réglementer les
voitures je pense que c'est moins grave
que de prendre tous les ans des millions
de réfugiés dont on sait pas quoi faire
alors votre démarche
ce consiste en quoi vous avez lancé un
manifeste et vous fait neuf propositions
acquis aux entreprises aux états pour
décarbonés l'europe d'ici à 2050 si on
veut vraiment tenir l'objectif de
l'accord de paris c'est-à-dire les deux
degrés maximum de hausse de la
température en un siècle
il faut que les émissions planétaires
soit divisé par trois d'ici à ce que nos
enfants et notre âge c'est très concrète
remplaçant futurs entrants con il faut
qu'on les rues et des mulets par trois
donc les générations futures c'est très
très clair très très simple c'est tous
les enfants de tous les gens qui nous
regardent donc décarbonée c'est pas pour
dans deux siècles
c'est vraiment pour maintenant et on
s'est dit bon maintenant on va faire une
règle de trois si on divise les
émissions par trois en trente ans ou 35
ans faut aller chercher les émissions là
où elles sont ou est ce qu'il ya des
émissions aujourd'hui par exemple dans
les centrales à charbon en europe 20%
des émissions européennes dans
l'alimentation 25% des émissions
européennes et une énorme partie dans le
cheptel bovin dans les transports 20%
des émissions et donc si on divise sa
part 3 on peut pas dire juste on va
s'occuper d'un petit morceau dans un
coin en objet de taper dans le dur
alors qu'en est il de la réception de
l'accueil de ces de ces mesures par les
chefs d'entreprises et par les
dirigeants les chefs d'état on a réussi
à obtenir une centaine de signatures de
chef d'entreprise on a on a été très
agréablement surpris
en gros on a eu un accueil positif sur
deux sollicitations qu'on a fait donc on
a un chef d'entreprise sur deux qu'on a
sollicité qui a dit oui mais les grandes
entreprises sous écoute change les
bourses soient les toutes les grandes
entreprises
non parce que les grandes entreprises
c'est pas monolithique monsieur par
contre un certain nombre de grandes
entreprises
oui les patrons ont signé on a tout eu
entre je prends sur moi de dire oui et
des gens qui ont fait voter leur conseil
d'administration
la macif par exemple mutuelle bien connu
le président de la macif a fait voter
son conseil d'administration mais mais
des industries qui produisent du lourd
aussi dans le fossile dans l'industrie
mécanique de transformation est ce que
met on a eu on a eu des signataires dans
ce monde là par exemple vallourec qui
produit des tubes en acier pour un
aciériste ans c'est quand même assez à
ces voleurs du pétrole notamment
alors pour l'univers du pétrole
notamment absolument mais pas que
vallourec fait aussi des tubes pour
l'industrie nucléaire et vallourec est
très intéressé par une industrie qui
pourrait être intéressante pour euh
pardon de la répétition qui est le fait
de remettre le co2 sous terre après
avoir brûlé n'importe quoi alors est-ce
que les pétroliers et gaziers les
producteurs d'énergies fossiles
or charbon qui ont pour un certain
nombre il ya eu le geste y aille c'est à
dire une initiative au monde la coop 21
et pétroliers et gaziers est ce qu'ils
ont ayant affirmé avoir conscience du la
transition de l'absolue nécessité de la
transition énergétique
est-ce qu'ils vous suivent est ce qu'au
moins il vous écoute c'est pas pour leur
jeter des fleurs mais la première
société du cac 40 qui est fait une
journée entière pour ses dirigeants deux
fois pour les cadres de direction 1904
de direction je peux le site et à
l'époque sous la houlette de thierry
desmarest
c'était total potasse qui voit là c'est
une solitude en 2006 je me rappelle
comme si c'était hier la première fois
que ça arrive et ils ont invité les
scientifiques orthodoxe qu'il fallait
inviter pour ça mais de valeur que dans
le monde gazier à la même époque il y
avait des climato-sceptiques partout et
il en reste une trace à mon avis
aujourd'hui et je n'ai jamais trouvé il
y en a probablement moins mais je n'ai
jamais trouvé chez total de 4,2
direction climato sceptiques dont disent
clairement ça leur pose un problème
business 1 aujourd'hui fend d'un produit
qui contribue à émettre du co2 mais il
ne dit pas le problème alors que dans le
monde gazier on continue à en trouver
qui nie le problème donc le monde du
pétrole à quelque part une attitude plus
plus cash plus carrée sur cette affaire
dont il jouit oui on est du mauvais côté
de la barrière aujourd'hui mais on hamm
est le problème il n'y a pas de
discussion sur le fait le problème est à
un dossier scientifique étayé sérieux
solide
le premier passe en question après leur
marge de manoeuvre est elle dans cette
affaire elle est évidemment difficile à
apprécier
parce que ce que demande l'accord de
paris donc je leur dis hein c'est quand
même que d'ici à la deuxième moitié du
siècle
quelque part entre 2050 et 2080 il y ait
plus un gramme de pétrole utilisé sur
terre sauf éventuellement dans des
grosses installations centralisé où on
puisse capturer le co2 le remettre sous
terre mais en particulier ça veut dire
qu'on peut plus s'en servir dans les
voitures dire délibérément je suis
d'accord avec ça je comprends que ce
soit pas facile aujourd'hui
pourtant si on veut être sérieux sur la
question climatique c'est bien ça qui va
finir par falloir arriver à faire alors
où est ce qu'on peut trouver jean marc
jancovici le détail du manifeste du
shift project vos neuf propositions sur
internet peut être un livre aussi
il ya un site qui est dédié au manifeste
qui s'appelle dit carbonneau europe.org
sur lequel on peut trouver le texte du
manifeste
le résumé des neuf propositions et pour
chacune des propositions 20 pages
d'explications et effectivement
l'ensemble du manifeste et des neuf
propositions sortira chez odile jacob on
met sous forme papier puisqu'un certain
nombre de gens qui aiment le paquet
merci d'avoir accepté cette interview
cette balade en paix car à bientôt pour
une lute peu car sur politique
énergétique
[Musique]